hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president biden signing more than three
dozen executive actions in his first
week in office
concerning the economy climate change
and immigration
as he re-establishes relationships with
world leaders what will be his most
pressing foreign policy challenge guest
host fox news correspondent gillian
turner speaks
to fox news senior strategic analyst
retired general jack
keane about how the biden administration
should address global concerns
including iran and russia and while the
covet 19
vaccine rollout appears to offer a way
out of the pandemic there are still
questions about the timeline of it all
fox news sunday host chris wallace
weighs in on vaccines
the debate over president biden's
executive order blitz
and former president trump's second
impeachment trial
plus commentary from fox nation host
tammy bruce
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com i'm dana
perino i'm juan williams i'm kennedy and
this
is the fox news rundown
friday january 29 2021 i'm jillian
turner
fox news senior strategic analyst
retired general jack keane discusses
some of the international
hot spots a new biden administration
will be forced to address
i do think that rhetoric dealing with
particularly putin will probably be a
little stronger doesn't necessarily mean
their actions
are going to be any stronger i'm chris
foster president biden's been busy
signing executive order since taking
office
including some about climate change
there is a cost benefit
obviously you want to do everything you
can to stop the the emission of
greenhouse gases on the other hand
weaning us off uh fossil fuels
does have a price and a very real price
in terms of jobs and in many cases very
good paying jobs we speak with fox news
sunday host chris wallace
and i'm tammy bruce i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
president joe biden is wrapping up his
first full week in the white house
he's focused much of his attention so
far on domestic
issues so what are the biggest immediate
challenges the new commander in chief
faces overseas what can he
put off for a while and what does he
have to focus on starting right now
president biden will have to navigate a
world full of hot spots including iran
and russia and china earlier this week
centcom confirmed two american b-52
bombers flew a non-stop
30-plus hour round-trip mission from the
u.s to the mideast
to send a fresh warning to iran the
united states has had some intelligence
for some time
that the iranians are moving through
their proxies some
rockets and missiles into iraq general
jack keane is a retired four star
general
the chairman of the institute for the
study of war and a fox news
senior strategic analyst and i believe
that this
and other activities that the united
states military has been conducting in
the last several months
is more of a deterrent to dissuade them
from
from using those rockets and missiles
against u.s troops in iraq i think
that's
largely uh what the issue is
um and and i as long as that threat is
there i think
probably some of that will continue as
we go forward
general when you say deterrence do you
mean they're flying these missions
to hopefully prevent any kind of armed
confrontation between the u.s and iran
yeah i think the united states has
intelligence that the iranians intended
to do just that
conduct some rocket and missile attacks
which they have done in the past
against u.s forces in iraq and
and flying these aircraft and
maintaining the kind of vigilance
that that we have is trying to
prevent the iranians from taking that
action and
having a military escalation you know in
the persian gulf as a result of it
let's talk about the iran nuclear deal
for a moment so biden's team has
indicated they want back
in but then this week iran's foreign
minister shut them down
saying iran's not going to bite first
the united states pulled out of the deal
so the u.s has to go back to the table
and sign up first before iran's even
going to consider talking about anything
what do you make of that well i think
it's typical iranians
they're hard ball negotiators the obama
biden team i think made far too many
concessions back in 2014
when they made put together the original
deal which did not include
anywhere anytime inspections it did not
include the
ballistic missile development it did not
include their
malign behavior in the region and of
course that established a sunset clause
which actually permits them to have a
nuclear weapons capability
and at the time 15 years now now it's 10
years so that
the deal um have a lot of flaws in it
and and i i'm concerned because
the people who will be negotiating this
deal were very much
involved in negotiating the last one
and wendy sherman was the chief
negotiator and she's now going to be
the deputy secretary of state jake
sullivan the national security advisor
was who is now the national security
adviser was involved in negotiations as
well
and the iranians play hardball even
though the iranians
uh jillian are in a much more desperate
situation because of the crippling
sanctions on them
and the leverage that the biden had
administration has
as a result of that and also because of
the
abraham accords which is the
normalization of
relationship between the arabs and the
israelis gives
the binding administration significant
upscale
in terms of upside in terms of leverage
let's move on to something completely
different now
troop drawdown so the trump
administration began withdrawing from
iraq and afghanistan there's only a
couple thousand troops left in these two
countries now
so do you think biden's going to
continue down this path or is he going
to freeze things where they are
or even send more troops back into iraq
or afghanistan
i think what they're going to do and
it's and i believe it's already begun
by the department of defense uh for sure
as well as the national security adviser
and that is to reassess where where are
we really
when it comes to afghanistan i thought
the deal that the united states made
with the taliban was horrific
it was not in the united states interest
we made a deal
with the taliban and and uh
we didn't insist on a cease-fire as a
result of that
they're negotiating with the afghans
right now and violence could never
is had a high high point literally
raging out of control
and that should have been a condition
for negotiations themselves
we're not in other words we're not going
to negotiate until both sides
agree to stop shooting at each other so
we can have meaningful negotiations i
think that's
literally step one in the reassessment
of the situation in afghanistan
and i think we'll discover that the
biden administration will probably want
to set some conditions
with the taliban in terms of imposing
their own will
on what's taking place otherwise if we
had to
continue to head towards the exits in
may the afghanistan is going to turn
into a
a bona fide civil war as a result of the
turmoil that will come
by completely walking away and it
pertains to iraq
i think they they likely have made up
their minds and they're going to keep
the forces
there in iraq at least for the near term
and assess whether the number of forces
that are there
are adequate for the missions that have
been assigned
let's move on to russia now before we
let you go general so
president biden has spoken to vladimir
putin now and according to the white
house biden really pushed him on the
solar wind hack and the detention of
russian dissident
alexey navalny so the white house is
clearly trying to make the case that
biden is going to be tough on russia
do you buy that and also it's a little
early to start comparing baden and trump
on the issues but can you believe
anything so far um is similar between
their approaches to russia
well i do think that rhetoric uh dealing
with
particularly putin will probably be a
little stronger it doesn't necessarily
mean their actions
are going to be any stronger uh you know
president trump
when it came to putin he mostly uh
believed in personal diplomacy and he
was not a critic
of putin's although his policy actions
were and the united states did take
issue with him
i'm not that concerned about the tone i
believe
in bringing these subjects up with putin
if appropriate but
putin just blows all of that off i mean
he's
he's done that with obama for years i
think
he was inside obama's head to be frank i
think he had
considerable leverage with him he also
had some leverage with george w
bush when george w bush uh
sort of fell in love with his
personality and uh
he's he knows how to handle american
presidents
putin is a is a master at it he's been
in power for 20 years
and you know you can throw all this
rhetoric at him all day long
and he just deflects it even he even
deflects the sanctions the sanctions
that have been posed on him and had no
behavior modification whatsoever
he's got his national interests and he's
going to pursue those national interests
at and they are largely at the expense
of the united states i think his
behavior
will be very consistent as he tries to
weaken the transatlantic alliance on
nato and have influence over eastern
europe
and also strategically in the middle
east
last question for you general so both
biden and putin say they want to extend
the new start treaty for five more years
they want it to start pretty soon on
february 5th
is this a good thing for u.s national
security interests
does it make us any safer from the
nuclear threat
yes it does make us safer this is
our strategic nuclear triad that we're
talking about where both countries are
held to
1550 warheads
i actually preferred what the trump
administration was doing
was trying to negotiate the details of
this because the deal
favors russia who has done a
considerable amount of expansion
of their nuclear weapons and we wanted
to make certain
that the inspections were had a little
bit more verification to it than what
they currently do
and we were at an impasse with the
russians and i think what we were going
to do
under the trump administration is taking
six months
extend the deal six months or extended
to a year
to continue negotiations it appears that
the biden administration
is just accepting all the conditions as
they currently are
and go ahead and extending it for five
years
overall that is good that the treaty is
still in place
but i do think there was an opportunity
to actually make that treaty stronger if
we were willing to negotiate a little
bit longer as opposed to
just accepting it as is all right
general jack keane thank you so much for
joining us today we learned a lot from
you
as we always do well great talking to
you and your audience
[Music]
this is tammy bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up
president biden ends his first full week
in office having signed dozens of
executive actions and orders covering a
theme a day like buy american
fighting the coronavirus pandemic and
climate change under the previous
administration
the federal government contract awarded
directly to foreign companies went up
30 percent that is going to change on
our watch
the end goal is to beat covert 90.
when i think of climate change i think
of the answers to it i think of
jobs there have also been orders
regarding health care racial equity and
more
around two dozen so far by far more than
any other president this early in his
term plus executive actions that are
more like
non-legally binding items on a wish list
when you add up all the
the numbers of executive orders and
executive actions
by joe biden it is you know a magnitude
exponentially
higher not only than trump but obama and
bush chris wallace is the host of fox
news sunday my general feeling is if
you're a democrat
and the new york times says enough
already
it's probably time to stop yeah pretty
ambitious on climate change and the
environment to the point where he's
telling federal agencies to consider it
in every decision you make
this of course sets up the usual
environment versus jobs
thing president biden says you can take
care of both republicans say he's
abandoning workers in oil and gas and
pipeline construction
well look it was no secret that this
president said he was going to be very
focused on climate change i happen to
believe in climate change
and you know i don't even know it's to
me it's like saying i believe in gravity
uh and and that we need to do something
about it
on the other hand you know that there's
there's a cost there is a cost benefit
uh obviously you want to do everything
you can to stop the
the emission of greenhouse gases on the
other hand weaning us
off uh fossil fuels does have
a price and a very real price in terms
of jobs and in many cases very good
paying jobs
and you know for biden or john kerry to
say well
you know we're going to get them out of
the coal mines we'll get them out of the
oil fields and they'll be
solar in the solar power and wind
turbines uh
you know first of all i'm not sure that
it's a one-for-one change i'm not sure
that the same number of jobs
that are needed although those green
energy are the some of the fastest
growing industries
and secondly i'm not i i really doesn't
appear that there
are um you know as good paying jobs you
know you're sometimes talking about a
25 000 job replacing a hundred thousand
dollar job so
i if you're going to do this and i
there's an argument to be made for
it seems to me that the the the
government has to be
sensitive to the fact that you're going
to dislocate a lot of people
you're going to cost them their jobs and
even if you can give them a new job
it's not going to pay nearly as much and
they have to have a program
to to ease that transition and to
pretend that it's not going to be
painful
is uh first of all people aren't going
to believe it and particularly the
people that matter the most
who are going to lose their jobs know
better
chuck schumer says the senate will start
debating
a new covet financial relief bill next
week he says the republicans don't go
along with it where
democrats will just do it without them
so do they go big or they go bipartisan
well you know there's an interesting uh
article today i know i read i'm sure you
do too so many things the papers
various political newsletters and one of
them have
what seems to be not certain but
but an idea of what uh
the the biden administration and the
democrats particularly in the senate
might do
and that is that you do both you go
bipartisan
on covet rescue and by that you take out
some of the things that uh that
republicans won't sign on to
uh and then you know there's a real
question is to even if you go smaller
and strip out just the more popular
things like the fourteen hundred dollar
uh direct payments and maybe you don't
make that for everybody
under a certain income level maybe you
target it more to people who
have lost their jobs make it much more
needs-based uh
you go smaller on that and you pass that
on a bipartisan level
if you can get buy-in and the things
that you strip out
you put in the recovery plan which is
something they're going to do anyway
and you do that on a on a budget
reconciliation basis
which for those of folks out there who
have a life and don't know all this uh
parliamentary arcania is
would allow you to pass it in the senate
with a simple majority of 50 votes
so maybe you you go to the principal a
bipartisanship with a smaller
more uh you know less ambitious
coveted rescue package and you put the
rest into uh
a recovery plan that you are going to
end up having to pass by reconciliation
anyway
yeah i read the same thing you didn't
apologize apologies to whoever reported
i just can't remember now um
because i read a lot this morning uh but
the white house already pushed back and
said nope we're not doing it it's
it's all or nothing that could just be a
bluff i suppose
well i don't know i mean there's clearly
not going to get
10 democrat republican votes to beat a
filibuster
for anything close to the 1.9 trillion
what
they were talking about in a narrow
package was more in the nature of
five to 600 billion which you know i
remember when five to 600 billion was a
big deal now it's like oh well we're
just gonna go down
to five or six hundred billion uh you
know that they would do it in a much
more i'm i'm not sure you get ten votes
for that
but it seems to me particularly if
you're biden
and and who he is and what he's talking
about in bipartisanship
and unity and civility and government it
seems to me you want to make
an effort to get something through
on a bipartisan basis you i mean if you
go right away to reconciliation and
right away you pass something jam it
down on a straight party line vote
uh uh of reconciliation which is 50
votes plus kamala harris
and you don't have you don't get any
republican buy-in
um i you know it doesn't send a very
good message and it really i think
basically says this is going to be all
about
us getting through everything we can and
forget the other party and i that i know
that isn't the tone
that that joe biden wants is that and i
frankly i don't think that's what he
believes in you know
he may be old-fashioned in this regard
but i think he genuinely believes that
you can legislate
and get a compromise uh there do not
appear to be the votes to convict
president trump in the senate when that
trial starts the week after next some
republicans say the whole thing's
unconstitutional because he's out of
office some say he didn't do anything
wrong
um i wonder if the trial had been rushed
like immediately after the right at the
capitol if there'd been more support for
it
yeah i mean i think there's certainly
that argument uh the converse argument
is that maybe you dig
some things up and find some things out
and it actually
makes it uh even you know clearer that
that
that president trump was responsible to
bear some
some responsibility for the attack on
the capital on january 6.
i look it he's not going to get
convicted he's not going to be barred
from
uh you know ever running for office
again
you had this procedural vote on whether
it was unconstitutional
they got 45 votes all they need is 38
to stop you know defeat any conviction
of the president so
there's no chance that that
donald trump short of some explosive new
revelation
uh is going to get convicted which then
raises the question what are you doing
this for it's slowing down your
confirmations it's slowing down
however do you decide to go ahead with
covid relief it
it it very much goes against this call
for unity and civility and government
it's going to be polarizing
and there are an increasing number of
democrats who say
forget about impeachment go for censure
it's a black mark um and and you know
it's something you can do as opposed to
if you go for the trial he's going to
end up not being convicted and i suppose
to some degree
president trump down in mar-a-lago
former president will be able to
view it as exoneration so look
having said all of that uh chuck schumer
is the senate
majority leader he's the boss and he
says we're going to have a trial so
they're going to have a trial
but i will say this it's going to be
short this is not going to be a two or
three week affair
if you told me it's going to last a week
i believe it
president biden's chronovirus task force
is planning to do these three time a
week
updates on vaccines and where things
stand at the moment with
uh wherever the pandemic is there's been
some mixed messaging on vaccines it'll
be spring it'll be summer it'll be fall
you know some people are criticizing
them we're sending mixed messages i mean
this isn't a science
we have found it out for all the science
involved in developing the vaccine
uh you know we have found producing the
vaccine and distributing the vaccine and
then
you know the last mile getting it into
people's arms
is a huge logistical challenge you know
i
to me i'm not going to hold i i think
it's important to do it as fast as
possible i'm not going to say
uh you know the the throw of a
penalty flag because one guy says it's
going to be summer and the other person
says it's going to be the fall i mean we
know it's going to be months and they're
going to do it
as fast as they can um
you know i myself i'm i'm uh
give the obama i give biden and his team
high marks for being as transparent as
they are we i had rate of rachelle
walensky the new head of the cdc uh an
infectious disease doctor on fox news
sunday and she said right now i can't
tell you
how many uh doses we have
i i actually gave her high marks i think
that brutal
transparency uh you know i know people
that don't like
biden are going to say well they can't
get their acts straight i'd rather have
honesty than spin and and you know if
people are saying
i mean in the end if some people are
saying it's going to be uh
summer and some people are saying fall
it doesn't make any practical difference
it'll
when you're when it's your turn you'll
be able to get it i mean i'm
now in a group that should be able to
get it i can't get it you know i
i literally uh went to
uh some some of the places that are
dispensing it because i had heard these
stories i'm sure you know that they're
out there
that at the end of the day if uh you
know they if some people don't show up
maybe they'll give the doses out to you
know
people flying standby they said no we're
going to keep it till tomorrow and you
can't get it
i didn't like it but that's the way it
is and i know they're doing the best
they can and i kind of accept that it's
a very
uh limited supply and a very precious
product at this point
and you know when i get the note it's
your turn i'll go in and get the vaccine
well just in case i'm going to walk
around in nothing but short sleeve
shirts just in case
a syringe happens to fly well i didn't i
was wearing a long sleeve shirt
and i thought wow this is going to
really be hard because this wasn't one
that was going to roll up easily but i'm
going to
have to be one of those people who
unbuttons the top and
bears my shoulder and has to get it but
you know what if i could get it
i'd be very happy chris lowes hosted fox
news sunday thanks a lot
you bet thank you chris
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information on your time
listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
london tut high school in sanger texas
has something most
schools don't have a grocery store it's
run by students and is there to address
food insecurity during the pandemic
anthony love is the school's principal
and says when he took the job he wasn't
expecting hunger and compassion to be
two of the main lessons
you know my first year being principal
you're thinking about you know
teachers and you're thinking about
curriculum and computer programs
and you know just preparing for the
school year and so it's kind of a
question that
catches you off guard because you're not
expecting it
um but you know it doesn't take long
just to realize the impact uh that it
can have on students
as well as the community the store
doesn't accept cash but instead uses a
point system
students can earn points for good deeds
by doing chores around school or helping
clean
hunter weirtman is a student who also
manages the store
i think it's very important because a
lot of people don't see the good that
can come out during the pandemic
and about the stuff that you can do even
though it's hard right now
the project is a partnership between a
ministry and a grocery store chain but
the students
are the ones that make it run they keep
up with the inventory stock the shelves
and monitor the registers
whirtman says he finds the work
rewarding i like seeing their smiles and
being like
how appreciative they are knowing that
they are thankful that we're doing
something like this
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
it's tammy
what's on your mind joe biden was
elevated into the presidency in part
because of misleading people about the
success of donald trump's attack plan
to mitigate the destruction of covet 19.
not the least of which was operation
warp speed delivering vaccines within a
year
president biden campaigned on having a
plan to defeat
covet 19. we are now being told by the
biden administration however that
president trump had no vaccine
distribution plan
a strange claim considering u.s news and
world report notes
that the centers for disease control and
prevention said it had administered 22
734 243 doses of covet 19 vaccines
in the country and distributed forty one
million four hundred and eighteen
thousand three hundred twenty five doses
an objective observer stationed on
planet earth would have to agree that
this is the result
of president trump's distribution plan
moreover just two days after being
inaugurated mr biden revealed
he has no plan at all at a press
conference he told the nation
there's nothing we can do to change the
trajectory of the pandemic
in the next several months besides
revealing the empty suit now in the
presidency
this also implies that masks and social
distancing
really aren't making a difference in all
fairness mr biden did have a plan
sort of his plan is to copy what mr
trump had already achieved
by the time mr biden entered office the
united states was vaccinating almost a
million people a day
that goal was suddenly one of the big
plans from the new administration
we know mr biden has a plagiarism
problem but when it comes to life and
death issues
it's even more unacceptable covet 19 has
been a disaster for the world
the virus sent from china has killed
over 400 000 americans
with all issues americans deserve better
than elected leadership and bureaucratic
experts using a disaster for political
reasons
or to bolster their own grandiose view
of themselves
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa
just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it
on demand from fox news and amazon alexa
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes